a fire in the town of Calabasas damaged
some homes including this is we're not
making this up this is real
including the property of one of the
members of our show he even made the
local news as firefighters put out
hotspots in the Hills neighbors watched
thank you incredible those guys Wow they
say a thousand they say they never and
rich Rosenberg knows it got so close the
shed at the edge of his backyard caught
fire but firefighters quickly put it out
that's an amazing story and of course it
that is Richard lebombo Rosenberg right
there credible yeah this is a tell us
what happened your your shed it just
caught fire and you guys managed to put
it out the firefighters put it out
firefighters yeah yeah they're great job
you just stood around and watched them
but they pretty much did it yeah yeah
yeah well no they were lucky they were
there I have to say as your employer I
was struck by the size of your pool look
at this look at the size of it school
he's got a bigger pool than I do what
the hell am I paying you know you pull
through a tube for a living
you played three notes
[Applause]
well I like to take care of the people
who work for me after I humiliate them
so I did something I think is pretty
nice earlier today I went out and I
bought you Richie a brand new shed
check it out la Bamba I bought him a new
shed for his home
[Applause]
isn't that great Wow yeah look at that
this is a check it out this is a
top-of-the-line 8x8 foot garden shed
fully weatherized waterproof to provide
years of storage juice nothing too good
for our lebombo give my hand
[Applause]
get outside now that was really
thoughtful of you that's cool yeah yeah
a nice job yeah I'm glad I could do that
for him it just occurred me when I was
watching the news we could do that it'd
be easy and I'm told is that right that
la Bamba is already enjoying his new
shed outside our studio right now let's
take a look I think we have cameras
there man that cone is a great guy
time for a celebrity creme brulee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have nine problems with the end of
that I know
he said celeb celebrity yeah when it's
celebratory yeah that's not really a
word yeah okay so that's not a word yeah
those special effects were off right why
does why does a creme brulee make the
shed blow up make the shed blow up yeah
and now he's dead but we all know when
we come back from the next commercial he
oh he's back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
groans around here what are you what are
you freakin Jon Snow
you